[Music]
this is an evital craft it stands for
electric vertical takeoff and landing
basically it's a flying car but despite
what back to the future told me where
we're going we don't need roads
i'm yet to be flying around cities like
doc brown or marty mcfly but a string of
startups like joby archer and lillium
are all trying to change that their aim
is to create a fleet of flying taxis
that could zip over buildings cut past
traffic and slash travel times saving a
billion people an hour every day but if
they're going to revolutionize how we
get around they're going to have to do
it quietly if they can't then their
businesses might not get off the ground
you see we already have aircraft that
zip over buildings and cut past traffic
and slash travel times
they're called helicopters the problem
is that helicopters are loud
like really loud and if they operated
like taxis do they create lots of noise
complaints so evital companies are
trying to make their aircraft as quiet
as possible we still have a long and
challenging journey ahead of us to get a
better idea of how they're sounding
right now some of them have turned to
nasa and nasa's role is really to
understand how we can enable the safety
efficiency and the scalability of these
operations that research will inform the
decisions that aviation regulators make
around ev sole noise and could impact
how our cities sound so what does the
future sound like let's find out
okay so before we get into what these
startups are doing i want to dive into
why ev tolls need to be quiet
because aviation noise pollution is more
than just annoying some studies suggest
that it can even be detrimental to
health potentially impacting everything
from reading comprehension in children
to cardiovascular health in adults to
mitigate this the faa has been
monitoring the effects of noise
pollution and has drawn up certification
standards that aircraft have to meet
what's interesting is they're not just
monitoring how loud an aircraft is but
they've also looked into how often
somebody might be exposed to that noise
and how annoyed they might become by it
that's important for these startups
because while many evital craft have
small distributed electric motors making
them much quieter than helicopters the
companies operating them plan on
creating a fleet of sky taxis this means
regular flights in and out of built up
areas which only works if the aircraft
is really quiet how quiet well it gets
complicated like really complicated but
as a starting point the industry tends
to agree that these aircraft need to be
under 65 decibels which is about the
same volume as a conversation
so to find out exactly how close they
are to that target ev toll startup joby
is utilizing nasa's mobile acoustics
facility which includes an array of more
than 50 microphones it has a set of
these wireless acoustic measurement
systems collecting
things that are in regards to the
intensity of the sound so the decibel
level along with the frequency of the
sound joby is working in partnership
with nasa and the faa as part of nasa's
advanced air mobility campaign which
will help inform the faas policies and
regulations around ev tolls and what
we're attempting to do is work closely
with industry such that we can collect
that data and inform
um the policies as they need to evolve
joby has been testing its four passenger
flying taxi which it plans to have in
operation by 2024. the company says
they're using electric motors and six
rotors instead of one to reduce noise
levels and right now they say their
craft is operating around that 65
decibel market takeoff but how loud an
eevee toll is may only be part of the
challenge
noise has an objective measurement as
well as a subjective component there's a
whole host of research that goes into
being able to characterize the noise and
then being able to utilize that joby
says it's also working on ways to make
its aircraft sound as pleasant as
possible or as their ceo puts it our
goal was to mimic the character of
natural sounds like the wind or the
ocean what's more the company says
they're trying to make the aircraft
sound imperceivable over the background
noise of a city
that may be the only way they'll find
success after all several studies around
aircraft noise point to two key findings
firstly that people find aircraft sound
more annoying than rail or road noise
and secondly over time we're getting
more and more annoyed so if the flying
car revolution is finally going to take
off it's going to have to do so quickly
and quietly
hey i could talk about ev tolls for days
and this video is really just the
beginning so if you're interested in the
future of how we might be getting around
don't forget to subscribe catch you
later